les agronomes le disent la plupart des
variétés qui pousse aujourd'hui dans nos
champs ne survivront pas aux changements
climatiques anticipé mais développer de
nouvelles variétés
ça prend du temps des chercheurs en
saskatchewan se sert donc de tout un
attirail technologique pour décupler
leur capacité d analyse sur le terrain
et accélérer le cycle de production de
nouvelles variétés saskatoon en plein
coeur des prairies canadiennes une ville
vibrant qui connaît l'un des taux de
croissance économique les plus élevés au
pays n'est de l'agriculture la ville est
reconnu aujourd'hui pour ses nombreux
centres de recherche et d'innovation
agricole à l'université de la
saskatchewan ces milliers de rectangle
dans les champs
ce sont des personnes expérimental de
blé de canola et de lentilles d'une
parcelle à l'autre les plantes se
distingue par deux toutes petites
variantes souvent invisibles à l'oeil nu
au cours des dernières décennies plus de
500 variétés de cultures ont été
développées ici des plantes plus
performante plus robuste cultivés à
grande échelle dans les prairies
mais le travail de sélection qui se fait
ici connaît depuis trois ans une
transformation majeure
un projet de recherche
multidisciplinaire est en cours qui
pourraient avoir des retombées énormes
sur notre sécurité alimentaire à long
terme nous créions de nouvelles méthodes
d'évaluation des plaintes basé sur la
capture d'image plus développant ici une
toute nouvelle démarche scientifique
[Musique]
juillet 2020
l'agronome steve sutcliffe et son équipe
entament leur premier vol de la journée
muni de sa caméra se drones survolent
400 parcelles de blé en 20 minutes
chaque semaine le drones survolent ces
parcelles
quand il atteint 30 mètres d'altitude il
prend une série de photos
chacune de ces personnes représentent un
croisement unique de blé
les chercheurs s'intéressent ses
différentes caractéristiques des plantes
leur taille la forme et la taille des
feuilles le nombre d'épis sur les tiges
et leurs couleurs
ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est
le couvert végétal des plantes créer une
sorte de panneau solaire
les feuilles près du sol absorbant les
rayons du soleil l'énergie emmagasinée
fixe le co2 et permet aux plans de
générer plus de grain quelques variantes
comme la taille des feuilles vont aussi
favoriser des rendements supérieurs
voici le fruit de leur travail
des centaines de photos des parcelles
qui sont assemblés comme un casse-tête
pour illustrer l'ensemble du champ un
travail qui se fait tout au long de la
saison sur des dizaines de champs et qui
permettent aux chercheurs de suivre en
détail le cycle de vie de plusieurs
millions de plants
l'analyse de cette banque gigantesque de
données se fait dans un tout autre
département de l'université
in-stat jeunesse et professeur de
sciences informatiques extraordinaire
des analyses de données qui a suscité
mon intérêt extraire le plus
d'informations possibles des parcelles
expérimentales pour les relier aux
profils génomiques de ses planques son
équipe développe des outils pour
cataloguer les images des personnes sur
plusieurs saisons et pour cerner des
traits spécifiques à différentes plantes
dans cette parcelle
il ya beaucoup plus de fleurs jaunes
alors que dans celle ci il y en a peu
c'est peut-être un signe que cette
variété de canola produira plus de grain
et aura donc un meilleur
le principal défi sera d'identifier de
compter ses fleurs puis de fournir un
chiffre précis au sélectionneur
[Musique]
traditionnellement l'évaluation des
caractéristiques des plantes sur le
terrain se fait à la main un travail
long et ardu
créer une nouvelle variété de cultures
selon l' approche conventionnelle peut
prendre jusqu'à 15 ans donc que tanner
est sélectionneur de plantes à
l'université du manitoba les plus
grandes erreurs en recherche sont
souvent de nature humaine par exemple
votre idée de la couleur verte est
différente d'alien nos préjugés infecte
nos perceptions
c'est donc préférable de toujours
privilégié d approche systématique et
fiable puis il y a le nombre faramineux
de plantes à évaluer en une seule saison
souvent les sélectionneurs n'y arrive
tout simplement pas non seulement on
examine chaque plante mais aussi chaque
organe de la plante
de cette manière on peut compter tous
les epide lit d'une parcelle par exemple
les sélectionneurs n'ont jamais fait ça
avant
parce que c'est trop laborieux
mais
l'utilisation de nouvelles technologies
est donc beaucoup plus efficace
l'imagerie perdront permettent entre
autres de capter des détails qu'on ne
peut voir à l'oeil nu
c'est le cas de ces images thermiques de
plantes analysés en laboratoire par le
chercheur est ma doudou d un défouloir
indices aux fruits plantes
voici différentes variétés de blé les
températures de surface varie d'une
parcelle à l'autre les parcelles plus
foncées sont celles qui dégagent le
moins de chaleur en général les
sélectionneurs cherche des variétés dont
les températures restent basses
car ça signifie que physiologiquement
elle résiste mieux à la chaleur nous
avons recueilli ces données pour deux à
trois mille parcelles en seulement 10
minutes
ces images permettent aussi de voir le
développement de pathogènes dans les
plantes un critère important de
sélection on peut voir les premiers
signes de maladie sur les feuilles aussi
la situation s'aggrave
on le verra sur nos images les ondes de
photosynthèse sur les feuilles seront
plus petites ailleurs sur le campus
un autre outil conçu sur mesure pour les
chercheurs est déployée
ce tracteur est munie de six caméras qui
sont braqués sur la récolte
pour
ah oui oui
ce système fournit des images encore
plus détaillées que celles prises avec
les drones
la chercheuse sans l'hiver se spécialise
dans la sélection de plantes
oléagineuses
elle évalue sur ces personnes l'impact
de différentes concentrations d'azoté
sur divers croisements de canola on
cherche un équilibre entre la quantité
de biomasse c'est à dire de feuilles et
le début de la floraison la saison de
croissance et courtes dans les prairies
donc si la floraison tarde trop et
rendements sont insuffisants on veut
minimiser l'apport d'azoté tout en
maximisant la production de canola
[Musique]
mais comment cette multi de ceux de
données permettent elles de créer plus
rapidement de nouvelles variétés
la réponse est dans ce laboratoire le
gimmick si angie shot dirige l'ensemble
du projet de recherche sa toile de fond
c'est le génome des cultures
individuelles et une gêne apparaît
toutes les plantes à l'intérieur de
chaque parcelle proviennent de génotype
unique
il devient alors possible d'obtenir une
sorte de signature de la réaction de la
plante au stress environnementaux ou
biologique rencontré au chant ça nous
permet d'isoler les jeunes souhaité puis
de sélectionner les plantes et plus
performante c'est efficace et rapide
un des grands objectifs du projet c'est
de fournir des outils aux sélectionneurs
de plantes pour pallier l'impact des
changements climatiques sur les cultures
dans cette serre par exemple on évalue
les rendements de diverses plantes de
canola lorsqu'elles sont privés d'eau on
évalue le rendement des différents
génotypes dans un environnement contrôlé
ce qui nous permet ensuite de transférer
les plus performants au chant
c'est une véritable course contre la
mort qui m'a change mais il est
difficile de prédire à quelle vitesse il
faut donc agir maintenant et développer
des outils qui nous permettront de créer
de nouvelles variétés rapidement c'est
une pièce essentielle du casse tête
les sélectionneurs de plantes constate
déjà que les variétés développer il y a
dix ans n'ont plus le même rendement
dockett année est convaincu que la
création de nouvelles variétés devra se
faire plus rapidement
à l'avenir la production agricole à
grande échelle risque fort bien d'en
dépendre les changements climatiques ça
ne veut pas dire que le climat change et
ça s'arrête là
c'est un mouvement en marche qui n'a pas
de frère j'espère que ces recherches
rendrons notre travail de sélection plus
efficaces et qu'elles nous permettront
de nous adapter rapidement
pour les chercheurs à l'université de la
saskatchewan
ce qui importe le plus c'est que les
outils qu'ils développent soit ensuite
disponible à grande échelle pour la
création des cultures de l'avenir au
canada mais aussi pour aider à assurer
la sécurité alimentaire
ailleurs dans le monde l'inde le
bangladesh comme plusieurs autres pays
émergents pratique la sélection des
cultures mais sans utiliser les
nouvelles technologies
on veut s'assurer qu'il y est un partage
mondial des connaissances des outils
technologiques pourraient devenir un
véritable filet de sécurité
toute la portion facile du travail de
sélection des cultures a été fait
maintenant il faut arriver à maintenir
les rendements à la hausse afin de
nourrir une population grandissante et
ça si tout un défi